la russie va expulser 36 diplomate
européen annoncé cet après midi du
ministère des affaires étrangères russe
et quand vous voyez ce qui se passe dans
le donbass plus que jamais il est
nécessaire d'arrêter les importations de
pétrole venu de russie l'homme
prétendait que depuis des semaines c'est
ce qui se prépare mais ces mini et bien
sûr que ce que nous préparons je ne le
cache pas peu importe le nombre de
soldats russes ne nous battrons nous
nous défendrons tous les jours nous ne
relancerons à rien de ce qui est
ukrainien les etats unis d'amérique et
les pays occidentaux font tout pour
faire traîner l'opération militaire
spéciale autant que possible
le volume croissant des livraisons
d'armes étrangères démontre clairement
leur intention de provoquer le régime de
kiev pour qu'ils se battent jusqu'au
dernier craignant de coin
conseil privé elle donnait dia
conseiller emmanuel maquet de 2017
bénévolement qui lui a permis d'être élu
bénévolement à qui vous donnez ensuite
des marchés publics je suis désolé mais
si vous voyez pas le problème c'est
extrêmement inquiétant pour l'état de la
démocratie française parfaitement
pardonnez moi dans le style et le ton je
pense qu'on peut baisser un petit peu
d'ailleurs ce soir qui vous est
caractérisée qui caractérise votre
compagne votre parti ne répondait sur
dénigrer calomniez il en restera
toujours quelque chose c'est une famille
à un clan qui depuis 8 élection
présidentielle défend les mêmes idées on
a changé parfois la façade pour les
rendre plus acceptable ou aller chercher
plus large mais je m'attendais quand je
dis ça ça n'est jamais mis de
l'agressivité unis du mépris non mais
évidemment qu'on n'est pas d'extrême
droite si nous étions d'extrême droite
ne remettions en cause le parlement nous
appellerions à la violence est ce que
vous nous avez vu faire ça fera choisir
c'est ça ne tient plus mais vous voyez
vous continuez encore sèche je suis un
peu étonné mais je pense que c'est en
réponse justement et cette diabolisation
qui à mon avis ne fonctionne un peu que
sur les plateaux télé dans les élites on
est mandat des policiers de courir après
des gens qui portent le voile pour leur
mettre des amendes que vous leur donnez
vous savez bien que c'est après des gens
pendant des moments vérifier si tu avais
bien cochée sur l'attestation c'est va
faire c'est qu'on pourra voir sortir
mais pouvoir respirer ça vivait dans la
rue et ça me rappelle une femme je suis
pas les merveilleuses elles sont
toujours d'actualité ces femmes qui
s'appelle le chat la belette petit lapin
lie à chaque chapelle raminagrobis un
chat dit lafontaine faisant la
chattemite ce chat il est tout doux tout
gentil et quand ce pauvre petit lapin et
cette pauvre bête arrive jusqu'à lui il
a les crocs et les mange pas c'est ça
derrière marine il ya toujours le pen il
faut quand même le rappeler pour
préparer le studio du débat de son
technicien travaille déjà depuis six
jours 23 caméras un plateau circulaire
c'est dans ce cadre que s'affronteront
les deux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle demain deux bureaux à
deux mètres cinquante de distance l'un
en face de l'autre j'espère que ce ne
sera pas ce que j'entends dans une
semaine c'est à dire une succession
d'invectivés technique aux doutes france
j'espère que tu auras pas d'agressivité
général y en avait la dernière fois oui
fait chez makro n'a pas manqué non plus
d'être agressif la dernière fois
j'espère que ce sera solennelle sérieux
arguments contre arguments projet contre
projet ça n'est pas sérieux de regarder
les français en leur disant vous n'aurez
plus d'impôts plus de taxes plus de
salaire vous travaillerez moins
longtemps personne ne peut y croire
parce que vous êtes crédibles avec 600
milliards d'euros de desvres marine le
pen s'est mise au calme chez elle pour
deux jours de travail avec ses
conseillers outre des fiches thématiques
qui lui seront préparés elle doit se
livrer à au moins deux débat factice
face à un énarque qui campera le rôle du
président sortant et qui lui ressemble
physiquement plusieurs lycées parisiens
sont bloqués comme vous voyez sur ces
images là ça se passe au lycée lamartine
qui est situé dans le 9e arrondissement
parisien et sur leurs pancartes on peut
lire des slogans hostiles à la fois à
marine le pen et à emmanuel macron un
mot dieu ce qu'on a appelé le pet
creston la période ont lancé par valérie
pécresse maya du monde a déjà un million
quatre cent mille euros récoltés pour la
candidate endettés